I would say that by virtue of having a
certain skin tone you are immediately
read in a particular way as a black
woman I just get questions a lot more in
every single field via dating do you
date white guys do they're black guys
like what's your five I don't know white
girl pink ask those questions being a
black woman you're dealing with first it
was for me as a race part and then you
do with the sexes on top of it some of
the ways that our attractiveness is
described can be quite dehumanizing I
quite often get cold you know milk
chocolate and you know while some people
see that as a massive compliment I see
that as humanizing and I feel like quite
often I'm sexualized in a way about
white women are there is this impression
that black women are these hyper sexual
you know creatures that can just be used
in a particular way and within that
depends on the shade of the black woman
there's a whole other issue I don't
expel with your things inside or outside
of your race there's so many myths about
how we're supposed to be in intimate
settings I think I think a lot of people
that need a men women you know clappy
for non black people they can project
certain expectations onto you because of
what they think there is definite
deception
black women sexually this I notice an
uptick in attention basically the second
I leave London because they kind of got
used to me and they kind of have all
these ideas and I was with a white
female friend and she was kind of
getting at her feelings about all the
attention I was getting and I was like
they are paying with energy because they
think I'm a prostitute the attention
that I get would really like provoke a
lot of my white female might be my
friends I feel like the nature of it is
is hard it's not respectful getting I
don't like it
not exactly I remember being told that I
don't have a typical black girl body
because I don't have thick thighs and a
big firm and huge boobs there isn't a
right way for a black woman to sign up
for herself without being seen as
aggressive where did these stereotypes
even come come from that's why I don't
know sometimes I feel like it's because
we've had to fight yeah yeah to be heard
[Music]
you've seen my blackness and you have
presumed that I don't have any effort
from all yeah I don't want to have an
altercation with the women as I was
waiting to get a train and she
so white women older accused me of
fishing in front of her and she typical
and I turned around to her and I was
like typical war and she had you know
she just said it without realizing you
know that I was gonna pick up and what
she's in Sydney wait day and I was like
typical what I was like typical black
that's what you meant I mean I'm really
quite nice I'm already quite friendly
but I have to be extra friendly have to
be super extra bones have to be very
like talkative just so people don't
think that I'm being standoffish people
are already ready to receive you in a
certain way regardless of how you've
interacted regardless of how you show up
that day regala says if you are angry or
not angry in that specific moment and
you probably have a lot to be angry
about anyway yeah yeah people are
already like projecting their ideas of
what you should be onto you and then if
you react to that and you are justified
be angry that it's doubled at home she's
got an attitude she's difficult if I
didn't like something I'm kind of stay
silent and because I didn't want to be
you know because I was like no problem
yeah so I didn't want to come across as
being a problem or angry kind of the
stigmas that kind of come sometimes when
you're voicing an opinion a black woman
saying upset but something quickly in
the workplace as well it's read in a
different way
if I cry I'm being hysterical if I speak
up and being loud and aggressive I've
got to toe the line when it comes to my
emotions and yeah it's tricky in terms
of this augment that effect black women
I would say that despite all the work
that's being done into social undo them
they are just as prevalent as ever it's
up to us to keep making noise and keep
demanding don't let the color of your
skin define you you are beyond being
black you are beyond being a woman you
are amazing that is what you should step
forward with